il ya eu il ya eu jeudi des réactions
très virulentes vous a fait le top 3 des
détracteurs à la télé sur ce nouveau
projet parce que c'en a parlé partout
bfm ils ont fait hier soir ce matin
c'est la journée ben voilà et il ya eu
des détracteurs au numéro 2 or numéro
trois honda me regarde et je crois que
c'est raphaël rémy ne le ch et pascal
praud ce matin sur ses news regardez
quand on est ministre qu'on est censé
lutter contre les discriminations pour
les droits des femmes et qu'on va servir
la soupe un animateur qui a été en
procès qui a été en procédure pardon
pour des questions d'homophobie et
d'agressions sexuelles dans les plateaux
et ça revient de manière répétée et là
et encore une procédure lancée avec sos
homophobie et bien je trouve que c'est
pas une bonne manière de lancer la la
deuxième partie de votre
de votre intervention est nulle et non
avenue vous pouvez pas faire à cyril le
assez minable le pensait d'être
homophobe enfin tu dire ça pas de ne
vois pas pourquoi pour une question de
principe
madame schiappa ne pourrait pas aller
chez monsieur amina qui n'a pas keane
qui n'est pas considérés comme
homophobes
tout le reste c'est de la littérature
alors voilà donc la raconter n'importe
quoi cette jeune fille je l'avais invité
sur le plateau
là c'est n'importe quoi je sais même pas
de quoi il part donc non je vous dis
vraiment en plus ils n'ont alors je vous
dis voilà donc c'est n'importe quoi oui
ne vous embêtez pas il ya des corps
partout et des cons partout c'est pas de
problème en fait je vais être très
honnête et sans flagornerie parce que
vous avez déjà animé des daubes ça vous
est arrivé
donc si saab était dans une autre
émission que dans tpm paix ou une
émission spéciale très honnêtement
j'aurais trouvé ça ridicule mais là
disons les choses
bravo à vous à vos équipes j'en sais
rien malon ton passelac savent pas ce
soir mans l'actualité c'est là que ça se
passe autrement les invités qu'il faut
avoir c'est là qu'ils sont j'adore
ruquier mais c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
il est un petit peu perdu la personne
qu'il faut avoir chaque semaine et dans
cette émission là on joue sa formidable
que dans cette émission est justement
qui regardaient par des jeunes et par
des gens qui ne sont pas spécialisés de
politique parce que quoi qu'on dise
j'écoute souvent jamais chat la bâtie
parfois c'est un petit peu de technique
quand même assez parfois entre pro et
parfois on se perd un petit peu que ça
puisse s'ouvrir à des gens un petit peu
plus simple on va dire en politique gens
qui sont un petit peu moins obtus là
dessus dit je trouve ça formidable et je
n'ai pas une émission de divertissement
exactement ce magicien magazine vous le
rappel de société voilà l'originalité
mais quand même revenir sur le mépris de
la sénatrice pardon mais un mépris de
classe absolue et moi je trouve que ça
ses rêves comme s'ils avaient des bons
téléspectateurs et des mauvais
téléspectateurs et je pense que les 700
mille téléspectateurs qui vous regardent
le vendredi soir pour ballast on
m'annonce ton poste sont des citoyens
pas de seconde zone et de noix cerises
et citoyen important et donc voilà donc
je suis évidemment choqué et je pense
que l'egypte les gilets jaunes ont
révolutionné le débat politique
oui et donc normalement on doit parler
aussi une sphère politique différemment
dans les émissions de télévision
donc elle n'a pas peur board sait très
bien qu'on macron se lève les manches il
va parler au maire c'est très bien c'est
une nouvelle manière de faire de la
politique et de communiquer il faut que
les gens les journalistes politiques
s'en rende compte
alors en humer un caillou valérie boyer
aussi d'un grand-angle sur bfm tv elle a
carrément peur qu'on fasse de la télé
réalité regarder
je ne voudrais pas que la crise sociale
la crise d'identité la crise de sens que
les français sont en train de vivre avec
beaucoup de souffrance se terminant
gaudriole ou en télé réalité c'est de ça
moi c'est ça qui m'inquiète beaucoup le
ministre se prête à un jeu
c'est en tout cas une émission de ce
type j'espère que ce sera pas du mépris
par rapport à la colère à la souffrance
des français alors les t-shirts et je
pense qu'elle a jamais vu l'émission non
cinq ans qu'elle dit non pas tout quoi
mais écoutons à on voit tout de suite
quelqu'un qui est complètement
déconnecté de la réalité
je mets tout s'arrête là d'ailleurs non
à d'autres est peut-être un peu plus
parce que cela permettrait peut-être un
peu sur terre non elle est allée très
loin tous afin justement cc principe
d'avoir ce débat avec alec mal amichia
pas c'est qu'il y aura des filets jaunes
y aura des citoyens lambda il y aura
tout le monde
quoi de plus démocratique de réuni voilà
l'ensemble des citoyens temps c'est ce
qu'on demande nous avant tout gentil
justement en tant que gilet jaune c'est
qu'on nous écoute qu'on nous entende et
qu'il n'est plus ce mépris de classe et
là ils ne font que mettre en évidence ce
qu'on dénonce depuis depuis plus de deux
mille politicien il dira jean claude
franchement vous m'avez dit je me
rappelle au départ cyril ramène ou des
politiques en face de nous convaincre
soit vous me l'avez demandé
je te ramène les nous en face de nous on
veut leur parler s'te plaît n'est pas là
quoi alors autant de gilet jaune refuse
de participer au débat
alors il ya encore un papier est ce que
vous dites on veut débattre mais
pourquoi vous refusez il ya ce vendredi
oui mais pas partout où je ne sais pas
mais et ligue drouet par exemple ses
frères il est venu chez moi eric drouhin
sur les banques est l'une des figures
majeures du mouvement a fait un texte
hier où il est hors de question de
participer à ce débat qui est dictée par
l'elysée
donc oui je veux dire c'est très facile
de faire du tir au pigeon avec les gens
qui vous critiquent parce qu'à mon avis
dessus sur wii à mon avis il est facile
ici de faire du tir au pigeon sûr mais
en même temps chacun dans des
contradictions s'avance que celle et
gilet jaune
il ya aussi des contradictions
visiblement tous viendrait sur votre
plateau et beaucoup refusent d'aller
dans les mairies ou dans des lieux où
sont organisées des réunions s'est pas
trompé mais là c'est pas une question
j'ai le joint tournant qui rayonne parce
que les citoyens sont exactement pareil
j'ai les gens n'ont pas gilet jaune
vous avez des citoyens clairon
volontiers part je parle au nom mais
justement pourquoi vous faites une
scission entre les jets régionaux et les
dres passe quand vous dites je vienne
avec plaisir ici je ne sais pas si vous
personnellement vous allez allez moi
personnel excusez moi je perds le mieux
que tu sois rentré vendredi
j'ai eu le mont mère encore au téléphone
aujourd'hui et je serai présent dans ma
mini mobilité en tant que citoyenne les
filets jaunes sont des citoyens engagés
n'est décidé alors c'est pas une
étiquette politique et je n'ai pas tout
de suite les gilet jaune tout comme les
autres citoyens sont tout à fait libres
d'aller où moins à ce grand débat c'est
pas parce qu'on sent bien chez les
jeunes
c'est pas parce qu'on en a pas que qu'on
y va forcément gémonies vous pouvez tous
vous ne vais pas dire pas vous
spécifiquement mais vous ne pouvez pas
dire le dialogue comme nous offre c'est
pas bien on voit pas de me parler mais
en tant que guide jaune valorise dia
logue ici alors vous me parler à moi en
tant qu'individu et moi en tant qu il
pensait du titre
alors donc en tant qu'un des fils aux
jeunes participent ces plaisirs et jaune
sont des citoyens ils sont libres ils
diront s'ils ont régalé et les autres
citoyens qui ne perd pas pied les jaunes
sont libres et ronces ils ont envie d
elle alors y'a pas de séparer la
population de j'aimerais qu'on revienne
sur le déferlement voilà qu'est
aujourd'hui la plusieurs l'ont traité
sort habitants leur nous on accepte
delajoux dit les critiques on accepte
que les gens donnent leur avis mais
c'est vrai que ça fait toute la journée
voilà et c'est normal la fntv mènera
c'est une chaîne voilà qui veut faire de
l'audience et apparemment voilà ça fait
soixante mille tweets ça fait énormément
parler aujourd'hui c'est hors habitants
je ne sais pas qui c'est voilà mais
regardez a été sur les grandes gueules
comme si je devais organiser un débat je
l'organisera dans un très beau lieu avec
des gens où ils ont pas l'habitude d'y
aller parce que je les respecte et parce
que je pense qu'il mérite d'être dans
des endroits plutôt prestigieux ben
pourquoi pas des gilet jaune à
versailles pour un débat au sénat ou
dans une grande salle s'est apprécié jeu
à plat cette année je n'en ai pas non
non non non mais je vous ai déjà mais
c'est pas la démagogie c'est que chez
hanouna c'est une émission de
divertissement c'est pas une émission
c'est pas touche pas mon post 1 tu as
bien compris c'est le vendredi soir son
spécial
hanouna combien de fois il a dérapé
combien de fois ce type a et et sexy que
jamais mais exactement l'association
niveau elle est incroyable d'attentats
parce que là c'est ce qui se passe à
goethe en train de dire là le confondent
tentacules et occulte attentes
c'est une émission de divertissement et
après balance en poste c'est une
émission où là il ya du débat sur et
c'est sérieux le show est complètement à
côté de la plaque
non mais en plus quand elle même jeudi
seule mère était choquée parce que je
voudrais bien vendredi en face à
l'elysée non mais ça ne voulait pas
s'asseoir et des petits canapés avec du
caviar quelque chose que vous ne
supportez pas c'est que l'on méprise
votre public où on insulte la en
estimant que ballon son poste et pas un
lieu pour faire un débat sociétal
j'imagine qu'on méprise aussi aux
téléspectateurs comment vous réagissez
comment vous levez vous si sa merci mais
vous êtes vous à question dans la mer je
veux pas revenir là dessus nous
franchement on donne la parole à tout le
monde ici on l'a toujours fait voilà
souli nous ce qu'on veut c'est que ça
avance que les choses avancent moi je
m'en fous totalement franchement je vous
dis c'est que des coups à prendre ces
trucs là vous pourrez rester dans le
divertissement faire notre truc
quand on a vu les gilet jaune et quand
on a vu quand j'ai parlé parce que c'est
pas l'émission se termine il rentre
chacun chez eux on essaie voilà de
parler après essayer d'arranger les
choses essayer de faire avancer les
choses mais c'est vrai et je me suis dit
moi y'a plein de mecs millions rien kiki
qui souffrent qui sont en galère
et qu'est ce que je pourrais faire pour
les aider c'est pas j'ai pas envie moi
de faire un débat voilà donc à la télé
puis une fois que tout le monde est
rentré mon massa lui qu'est ce qu'on
fait on sort on fait quoi avec tu les
oublies une fois que tu es chez toi et
j'adore par là le tout ces gens qui
parlent le ced le 7 novembre en question
et autres ensuite ils ont rien vu venir
donc là maintenant il se hisse mordent
les doigts en se disant on n'a rien vu
venir
vous vous étiez le premier à dire
attention et se passe réellement quelque
chose il ya une partie de la france qui
veut s'exprimer qui veut qu'on donne la
parole et vous lui avez donné la parole
après effectivement vous ne faites pas
partie du sérail donc ça peut être
fragile ans et plus 1